I have people ask me all the time, Nick, those that are in your program that take longer
to get deals, those that are struggling a little bit, those that, you know, haven't
got their deal yet, what are they doing wrong, what's going on, why, why, why, why, why,
why?
Well, I'm gonna tell you why, okay?
And it's something I really want to point out.
Some of you guys are coming to the table, some of you guys are just jumping to this
program, this is your first introduction to Rankin' Rent, okay?
Maybe you've done digital marketing, maybe this is your very first time doing a business,
maybe this is your first time doing an online business, whatever the case is, some of you
are brand new to this, others, some of you, or others, are coming and you guys have been
in Rankin' Rent for years, you've taken other programs, you've done other things, you've
been Udemy and whatever, Udemy and whatever, you've bought other courses, and you're coming
to the table with 5, 10, 15 websites, and guys, here's the cool part, you can use this
exact same process to sell other websites that are producing leads, okay?
But here's what I want you to be careful of, the number one thing that I see, the number
one hang up I see as far as people getting in the program, taking longer than they should
to get their first deal, is people, it's the following, okay?
People that come into this with existing websites, and in their head, they think the following,
okay, here's what I'm gonna do, Nick, I'm gonna come in, I've got 5 sites, I'm gonna
use this process, I'm gonna sell all 5, because I'm paying for hosting, I'm paying for phone
numbers, I'm paying for this and that and the rest, I'm gonna sell all 5 of those, get
clients, and then I'm gonna go do new projects, I'm gonna go pre-sell new websites, okay?
And I get it, in a perfect world, and with an engineered brain, everything fits into
a nice little box, and whatever, that's cool.
But guess what, here's what I would ask you, and this is what I want you to ask yourself
as you're going through this first module that you just went through.
If you had known what I just went through, the videos that we just went through, the
last few lessons that we just did, if you had known those things, and you're looking
at your site, maybe you got a site in, you got a roofing site in Ontario, Canada, okay?
If you had known what I just taught you, would you still have built this site, the one that
you're thinking of, the one that you're like, hey, I'm gonna go ahead and use this process
to sell it, would you still have built that site had you known what I just taught you?
If the answer is no, then I do not want you to use that as your first site.
I want you to either put it on the shelf and keep doing SEO, keep doing your regular thing
on it, or get rid of it, okay?
Because sometimes it's better just to cut it than try and squeeze blood out of a turnip
or whatever that saying is, okay?
And so what I've seen happen is people come in and they're like, hey, this site's getting
like two or three leads, and then you look at the market research, it's really competitive,
it's the wrong niche, the CPC is $10, $15, and they try and run it through this process,
they're like, oh my gosh, why is it not working?
Well, you're not following the criteria, you're not following the process that we just talked
about for the last couple hours, okay?
So here's what I want you to do.
If you have existing sites that are producing leads, what I want you to do is I want you
to run them through the exact same due diligence market research process that we just covered,
all of them.
Yes, I know, it's extra work, don't care.
Go and do that, and if those sites fit the criteria, they're low-hanging fruit, they're
layups, the CPC is under five but over zero, the volume matches, if those all check the
boxes, you got some freaking gold on your hands, baby, and you should use that website
first and you should go sell it, okay?
If they do not fit the criteria, then you either need to put it on the shelf and keep,
you know, do an SEO, doing your regular thing, or get rid of it, okay?
Sometimes the best thing is just to get rid of the dang site and go on to stuff that actually
works, okay?
Here's the game.
We need to get you to your first deal with this process, okay?
I don't care how much money you're already making, I want to get you, I need to get you
your first bit of money using this process, using the process, the results in advance
process that we teach in this program.
Why?
Because if you can get the first deal, there's this mental barrier that gets removed, you
go see it over and over and over, and there's tons of students in this program, some of
you guys that are watching this right now, you've seen it in your own business.
Takes you three years to get your first deal, you go in this program, you're in another
program for three years, you come in this, you get your first deal, and it takes three
weeks, and guess what?
Your second deal takes four days, or a week, or two weeks, but it happens right after,
and then guess what?
You get another one, and you get another one, and if you keep working, you keep getting
deals, so I know this game.
The game is I got to get you to getting your very first deal using this process.
I don't care if you've gotten previous deals, I don't care if you think you got deals because
you got paper lead and commission deals, or even if you got a flat fee deal, I want you
getting your first deal using this process, because what it's going to do is it's going
to give you trust, it's going to give you that confidence in this process, it's going
to remove that mental block that, oh, I can actually do this, and all of a sudden you
take off.
Guys, I just want to let you guys know before you go, I'm just going to go sell all these
sites because I don't want to pay for hosting, maybe what you need to do is get rid of those
sites.
I'm not telling you that's the case necessarily, but maybe you do.
Make sure that's the case before you just dive in.
For those of you that are brand new, don't even worry about it.
Follow the steps that we've talked about.
Pick the niche.
If you don't know what niche, pick concrete, do the homework, pick a great city.
Let's go make some money.
I'll see you guys in the next module.